bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv 78 depuis l'ugc et skywest
à montigny le bretonneux
nous sommes le jeudi 29 novembre tout de
suite les titres de cette édition on
parle de ce projet depuis une vingtaine
d'années l'enfouissement de la nationale
10 au niveau de trappes se précise des
travaux de dévoiement qui concerne les
réseaux d'eaux usées et pluviales sont
effectuées depuis cet été un préalable à
la construction d'un tunnel pour l'axé
routier nous avons pu visiter ce
chantier les entreprises yvelinoise
exporte près de 85 millions d'euros de
biens et services vers le canada d
échange simplifiée depuis la
ratification de l'accord de libre
échange du ceta est l'ambassadrice du
canada en france s'est rendu récemment
chez certaines sociétés concernées à
rambouillet et puis toute cette semaine
la ville de plaisir se mobilisaient
contre le handicap hier lors d'une
représentation les spectateurs se sont
retrouvés est les yeux bandés l'une des
animations proposées par l'association
valentin haüy au théâtre robert manuel
deux invités également dans ce journal
al islam candidat sans étiquette pour
l'élection municipale partielle à
coignières second tour ce dimanche il
fou chez président du conseil de
développement de saint quentin en
yvelines ils organisent les 14e
rencontres et lucau d'esquisser mardi
prochain je vous le disais avant les
titres nous sommes depuis l'ugc ciné
cité
skywest à montigny le bretonneux pour le
festival saint quentin c'est le festival
du film documentaire organisé par tv 78
jusqu'à dimanche 4e édition dédiée à
l'espace hier la soirée d'ouverture
s'est déroulée dans avec une émission
spéciale du paf
au programme de l'événement le festival
saint quentin ce sont huit films en
compétition des projections de grands
classiques ou encore des animations
enfin
ces animations sont seconds vont se
poursuivre dont une soirée spéciale
pardon ce soir que je vous présenterai
tout à l'heure ce n'est pas une première
pour c'est une première étape on va y
arriver c'est une première étape pour le
chantier de la nationale 10 à trappes
dans les premières réflexions remonte à
près de 20 ans des travaux se déroulent
en ce moment pour les réseaux d'eaux
usées et pluviales
ils ont démarré cet été un préalable à
l'enfouissement de l'axé routier ou 80
mille véhicules circulent chaque jour et
les précisions de mélanie poker et de
patrick jacques de dixmude faire que le
projet d'aménagement concernera un
passage souterrain pour les piétons le
souhait de sept trappistes verra bientôt
le jour
mais c'est la nationale 10 qui sera
souterraine elle les travaux ont débuté
l'été dernier au niveau de l'île de
loisirs des travaux de dévoiement
préalable à l'enfouissement
donc ces techniques sans tranchée en
l'occurrence comme vous pouvez le voir
c'est du forage à la tarière voilà donc
le forage à la tarière ça consiste à
passer un tour en acier d'un sous sol et
de faire une escale à sion avec une
tarière tout simplement un chantier
préalables à la construction du tunnel
une première étape d'un montant de plus
de 4 millions d'euros
ces réseaux reprennent tout simplement
une fois alors dévoiement fait les
réseaux d'origine qui était de part et
d'autre de la nationale 10 pour aller
pour notamment pour le pluvial à la base
de saint quentin en yvelines sur l'étang
inter
dire c'est juste un dévoiement avec
quelques améliorations on profite par là
par là par là même pour remettre à
niveau
certains réseaux mais l'objet du
chantier c'est le dévoiement des réseaux
pour garder ce système gravitaire
nécessaire à l'écoulement des eaux de
part et d'autre de la nationale 10 cette
partie du chantier doit prendre fin en
août 2019
la prochaine étape l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 3 ans de travaux et 100
millions d'euros seront nécessaires
en bref un proviseur de lycée frappé par
un élève les faits se sont déroulés hier
matin à l'établissement dumont d'urville
à maurepas l'adolescent de 16 ans s'est
ensuite rendu dans l'après midi il a été
placé en garde à vue à trappes
le proviseur souffre de douleurs à la
tête ses collègues professeurs ont
décidé d'exercer leur droit de retrait
ce jeudi environ 290 personnes mises à
l'abri aujourd'hui par la préfecture des
yvelines se sont pour la plupart des
demandeurs d'asile et des réfugiés
originaires du tibet il habitait un
campement de fortune à achères pour les
héberger des bâtiments ont été mises à
disposition au chesnay au vésinet et à
chatou on l'a appris hier l'hippodrome
de maisons laffitte va bien fermer à la
fin 2019 annonce de france galop qui se
réunissait en comité d'entreprise
opposition de la mairie qui a lancé une
pétition en ligne selon la municipalité
400 emplois directs et indirects sont
générés par cet hippodrome l'actualité
en ile de france la région a présenté
cette semaine son budget pour l'année
prochaine à retenir des investissements
revu à la hausse notamment dans le
secteur des transports
un budget qui garde le cap de la rigueur
les détails avec ce sujet et de nos
confrères de via grand paris continué à
investir avec un budget en baisse
la présidente de la région ile de france
a présenté ses choix pour l'année 2010
neuf premiers enseignements avec 2
milliards d'euros les dépenses de
fonctionnement diminuent -1 2% par
rapport à 2018
l'investissement lui augmente
l'enveloppé qui lui est consacré ce
chiffre à 2,1 milliards d'euros
ses + 7 % en 2019 c'est tout l'objectif
du déménagement de la région à
saint-ouen qui nous permet de réaliser
des économies considérables de
fonctionnement c'est aussi tout
l'objectif de la rationalisation des
structures para régional que nous
réintégrons dans la région sur trois ans
et un milliard d'euros d'économies qui
ont été faites premier poste budgétaire
les transports il atteindra 1,53
milliard dont 750 millions d'euros
d'investissement nous allons faire des
investissements qui vont être très
importants 7000 places de parking
igo supplémentaires pour pouvoir garer
son vélo et le sécuriser
8000 places de parking relais
supplémentaires pour pouvoir garer sa
voiture à proximité des gares mille bus
supplémentaires qui vont circuler là
aussi sur les routes d'ile-de-france
pour permettre à ceux qui n'ont
aujourd'hui pas la possibilité de ne pas
prendre leur voiture
le budget global consacré au lycée est
en hausse 1,27 milliard contre 779
millions d'euros en 2018 second tour de
l'élection municipale partielle à
coignières ce dimanche les électeurs
peuvent voter de 8 heures à 18 heures de
bureaux de vote pour ce faire à la
mairie à l'école bouvet bonsoir ali
bousselham bonsoir ce canal et vous êtes
votre avis tu as merci d'être venu alors
vous êtes candidat sans étiquette pour
la liste coignières avenir tête de liste
de cette tête de liste de cette liste
scolaire à venir et vous avez recueilli
dimanche au premier tour 36 30 % des
suffrages soit 573 voix vous êtes classé
deuxième de ce premier tour est ce que
vous avez été déçu ou satisfait de ce
résultat
ou plutôt satisfaits pour une première
fois quand vous le savez sans étiquette
en ce qui me concerne c'est une réalité
très concrète je n'ai aucune
appartenance antérieures quelconque
parti politique
et oui plutôt satisfaits effectivement
un autre candidat s'est placé mieux que
moi au premier tour tout le monde sait
que les plus expérimentés dans ce type
d'exercice
j'ai appris donc également hier que
monsieur pelletier sûrs retiré de la
coupe de cheveux et éthique qui était
troisième candidats engagés dans ces
cas-là il ya aussi effectivement on ne
peut que saluer une décision aussi
courageuse pas ce que c'est
c'est pas facile à prendre comme
décision de se retirer comme ça d'une
élection je trouve ça assez remarquable
en termes de courage et d'audace et vous
serez opposé dimanche vous en parliez à
didier fischer qui est également
candidat sans étiquette pour la liste
nouvel élan à coignières comment se
prépare le second tour à quoi
ressemblent vos journées depuis dimanche
eh bien écoutez on fait je suppose comme
notre équipe concurrente
on fait un peu de porte à porte un petit
peu de rencontres à droite à gauche on
tracte également voilà on fait le job
pour pour faire une campagne digne d'une
part et puis avec avec des vraies
promesses qui ce contenu c'est très
important notre petite différence c'est
que nous c'est pas un nouvel élan nous
on n'a jamais cessé de ce trailer n'est
pas fini et encore bon c'est un bon élan
donc nous allons nous mettre au travail
si nous sommes choisis par les connais
rien très vite l avantage de notre
équipe qui est très très très diverses
il ya deux tiers de personnes nouvelles
d'une part mais avec des compétences et
une richesse personnelle très profitable
à terme pour les poignées rien parce que
mettront toute leur compétence et leur
aptitude à leur service d'une part et
d'autre part une partie un tiers de gens
expérimentés pour être opérationnel
immédiatement dès le lendemain du
deuxième tour si les connais rien se
décide à venir nous voir
concernant les résultats je fais juste
un petit camp brouillait les airs d'été
le grand gagnant reste quand même
l'abstention alors justement j'allais
vous faire réagir sur cette
participation environ 47% c'est bientôt
c'est peu c'est moins d'un coignard bien
sûr d'aller voter
d'après ce que j'ai bien tout comprendre
en sciences politiques il semblerait que
dans une partielle s'est fait rarement
plus de 40%
d'une manière générale sauf que là c'est
un cas particulier
nous sommes dans une situation inédite
et singulière
et au regard des mobilisations
antérieures qui se sont produites dans
notre ville je vous cache pas que
j'espérais un plus grand nombre de quoi
n'y ait rien que se déplaçant vers les
ions donc je les exhorte encore à
nouveau à venir voter nombreux parce que
ça donnera plus de sens au résultat la
plus de koné rien participants et plus
effectivement quel que soit leur choix
ça lui donnera plus de sens et plus
d'impact l'appel est lancé alors pour
terminer rappelé les principaux points
de votre programme quelles sont les
priorités nous avez pu remarquer qu'il y
avait quand même de sérieux cousinage
entre les trois programmes celui qui
couve des candidats qui dirait le
contraire ne dirais pas exactement la
réalité la réalité c'est
qu'effectivement nous avons pour
ambition effectivement de de remettre en
état un certain nombre de bâtiments
d'équipement revoir le père lui parce
qu'il le défavorise il n'a pas pris en
compte de nombreuses remarques de nos
attentes de nos poignets rien mettre au
coeur de notre action la concertation
c'est à dire que de nombreuses attentes
il ya eu un déficit de concertation se
mettent autour d'une table posée les
projets les discuter et évaluer leur
faisabilité
ça je me suis engagé à le faire
également avec mon équipe bien
évidemment je me suis engagé à le faire
il n'y a pas de projet incongru tout
doit être mis sur la table
à partir de ce moment là on décide et
vous le savez on est élu pour l'instant
on serait élu pour 14 15 - accident les
prochaines élections seront en 2020
voilà donc comme les élections sera en
2020 il ya des actions qui vont être
immédiate parce qu'elles ont pouvoir une
réalisable et nous quand on connaît un
peu la mairie tout de même elles seront
faites et puis elle a d'autres qui sont
lancés à mort c'est parce que le temps
qui nous est dédié ne sera pas suffisant
pour aller jusqu'au bout de certains
projets mais peu importe s'ils sont dans
les tuyaux
c'est une chance pour les quads et de
les voir se réaliser une petite remarque
encore qu'un seconde quinzaine ont donc
simplement pour dire que j'ai de
l'expérience gérabilité membres de
l'ancienne majorité membres voilà
j'étais dans les différentes équipes
d'henri bayeux et j'ai agi pour la
jeunesse la culture est là et l'enfance
d'une manière plutôt remarquable
puisqu'il ya au moins au moins une
politique culturelle plutôt efficace
alcatel qui marche très bien
un accueil des jeunes et des enfants qui
est très très bien il ya un petit
bémol sur les 18 25 ans mais des projets
des ambitions pour eux merci à lee
bousselham d'abord été avec nous je
répétais rappelle que vous êtes candidat
sans étiquette pour le second tour des
municipales partielles à coignières tête
de liste de coignières à venir le second
tour de ces élections municipales
partielles c'est ce dimanche de bureau
de vote de vote ouverts de 8 heures à 18
heures en mairie et à l'école bouvet
vous serez opposé je rappelle ali ben
oui si l'ama didier fischer candidat
également sans étiquette saint quentin
en yvelines a accueilli à tedx saclay ce
mardi un village d'innovation à l'espace
saint quentin et une conférence durant
la soirée est des échanges et des
réflexions pu se faire entre les acteurs
de l'innovation numérique et de la
communication sur internet
les précisions de nicolas d'andry cet
impact vient du bang de la gestion des
données de l'intelligence artificielle
une révolution numérique au coeur de la
conférence du télex saclay 2018 organisé
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
parmi les intervenants des acteurs de
l'innovation avec des alertes concernant
le monde de l'information sur le web on
a le problème des fakes news on de la
pollution à des problèmes de diversité
informationnel avec des grands de
grandes entreprises technologiques comme
google twitter facebook qui monopolisent
l'information moments forts de cette
journée le village innovation à l'espace
saint quentin l'occasion de découvrir
différentes technologies du territoire
notamment une maquette reproduisant
l'industrie 4.0 mêlant impression 3d
réalité virtuelle gestion des données et
robotique
ici on a toute la phase personnalisation
clients et les clients peuvent commander
depuis chez eux grâce à des applications
qui vont leur permettre de demander
exactement le produit
qu'il souhaite ensuite ce set de données
client va être transformé en maquette
numérique pour que la conception de
leurs produits
ce soir sur un support numérique
accessible à tous les départements de
l'entreprise industrielle
si nous avons simulé la personnalisation
clients au moment de la fabrication les
acteurs de l'innovation déjà pris rendez
vous pour la cinquième édition du tedx
saclay en 2019 7,8 journal depuis l'ugc
ciné-cité skywest qui a accueilli hier
la soirée d'ouverture du festival saint
quentin quatrième édition de cet
événement du film documentaire consacrée
cette année à l'espace après l'ouverture
hier nouveau temps fort ce soir à l'ugc
skywest ça rappellera des souvenirs à
certains
une soirée temps x en présence des
frères igor et grichka bogdanoff
ils viennent pour la projection de leurs
documentaires sommes-nous seuls dans
l'univers qui sera suivie d'un échange
soirée animée par le journaliste jean
claude bourret et qui sera retransmise
en direct sur tv 78 aux alentours de 20h
nouvel invité avec moi en plateau jean
yves fouchet bonsoir pour soi vous êtes
le président du codis qui alors le coc
d'esquisser le conseil de développement
de saint quentin en yvelines
ils organisent ce conseil mardi prochain
à 18h les 14e rencontres et lucau des
skis c'est au campus et des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt déjà rappelé pour commencer
ce qu'elle co des skis c'est une
instance de démocratie participative à
saint quentin en yvelines
quelle est sa vocation au connaissent
presque tout dit tout les toutes les
agglomérations de plus de 1000 habitants
doivent normalement se doter d'un
conseil de développement qui est
constitué de d'habitants de
représentants associatifs
d'entrepreneurs de personnalité d'un
territoire qui sont désignés par les
différentes mairies et qui ont vocation
participer à la réflexion sur les grands
projets dudit territoire et on ne manque
pas de projets à saint quentin en
yvelines avec des forces importantes des
faiblesses aussi et donc on essaye de
porter aux élus des réponses à des
questions et puis aussi des axes de
travail et puis et puis parfois des
solutions
alors justement il ya un rendez vous
habituel chaque année avec son ces
réunions et lucau d'esquisser rencontre
et lucau des skis avant de parler du
thème précis cette année
le but de ces rencontres s'est échangé
avec les délits comme comme nous sommes
là pour faciliter la vie des élus leur
apporter des solutions
chaque année on essaie de se rencontrer
membre du codis qui est élu 2 saint
quentin en yvelines en général dias et
les élus communautaires mais aussi tous
les élus municipaux qui sont invités
tous ne viennent pas malheureusement
mais c'est la rencontre des élus et des
membres du cos des skis pour essayer de
faire avancer sur tel ou tel sujet cette
année c'est le sujet de la jeunesse et
plus particulièrement de ce2 de 16 21
ans qui sont entre le crb et le bts le
pré le thème précis oui les offres de
formation et d'emploi pour les diplômés
de ces élèves du cp au bts et pourquoi
proposer ce thème pourquoi se centrer
sur la jeunesse le codé ce qu'il fait
depuis quelques mois il ya une
thématique jeunesse qui respectait
aucune esquisse alors là il ya plusieurs
réponses dans le vent et g pourquoi ce
thème c'est ap au bts parce qu'on parle
beaucoup à juste titre de l'enseignement
supérieur voire très supérieurs et c'est
très bien sauf qu il nous a semblé que
tous nos enfants
toute notre jeunesse ne sera pas
forcément bac + 5
bac + 22 et qu en outre les entreprises
ont besoin au moins autant de
techniciens que d'ingénieurs et quand je
dis des entreprises servent à des
services à l'industrie numérique en
passant par le développement durable
donc qui nous a semblé qu'il est
important de mettre un focus sur ces
formations du ceap et au bts et le lieu
de la rencontre n'est forcément pas
anodin c'est le campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité qui a
ouvert ses portes à la rentrée de
septembre
lille jeunes ils sont en formation
quatre établissements toute formation
sur place absolument et ces jeunes en
formation sur ce campus sont en
formation du ca paix jusqu'au diplôme
d'ingénieur donc on aurait pu parler des
ingénieurs mais ça n'est pas été notre
choix cette année on parle de de ceux
qui sont dans cette formation intervenir
parce qu'on constate que les entreprises
en fait
manque plus de
diplômé entre le bac professionnel le
bts parfois un peu en dessous que ce
soit dans l'industrie encore une fois
mais aussi dans le bâtiment dont les
services la restauration etc et donc on
a voulu montrer que sur le territoire
il y avait des opportunités pour ces
jeunes aussi bien en termes de formation
avec ça va du lycée hôtelier toutes
sortes d'autres formations mais aussi
des offres d'emploi essayer de la
directrice de pôle emploi qui viendra
nous faire d'ailleurs un panorama avec
de nombreux élus de des intervenants de
bouygues construction de deux co de
korian qui l'établissement de services à
la personne et d'autres encore et je le
disais le codis qui a pas mal travaillé
sur le thème de la jeunesse sur ces
dernières années notamment la dernière
assemblée plénière avait pour but la
jeunesse vivre étudier travailler à
saint quentin en yvelines c'était le
thème absolument pas ce qu'on a fait un
constat on a travaillé sur deux grands
thèmes depuis deux ans qui sont le
projet de territoire d'une part et puis
le plh y le plan local de l'habitat
intercommunale et on a constaté que de
saint quentin avec toutes ses immenses
qualités avec un petit talon gheit
d'argile parce que la jeunesse des croix
donc on essaye d'apporter de proposer
des solutions pour que la jeunesse
viennent et reste à saint quentin en
yvelines
en trente secondes la suite de ces
rencontres à quoi vont elles servir par
la suite
alors on espère alimenter le débat entre
eux saint-quentin l'agglomération les
entreprises et les établissements de
formation pour que c'est cette partie de
deux niveaux de formation soit non pas
privilégier mes prises en considération
autant que toutes les autres merci see
et si je peux aller nous aurons encore
un peu de place sur moreau mardi soir
donc l'inscription se fait en ligne le
lien s'est affichée peut s'inscrire en
ligne sur le lien et une deuxième petite
information en 12 secondes
vous parliez de ce que l'on fait sur la
jeunesse on a lancé une grande enquête
auprès de toutes les jeunes saint
quentinois cette enquête elle elle aussi
en ligne sur le site
saint quentin c'est codé ce qu'ils
tiraient jeunesse point fr sur le site
de saint quentin
s'il vous plaît je n'ai jeunes saint
quentinois et d'ailleurs répondait on en
a besoin pour vous offrir le meilleur
saint-quentin demain le message est
passé merci ea foucher d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
président du coc des skis merci à vous
il a été ratifié par le parlement
européen en février 2010 est le ceta
accord de libre échange entre le canada
et l'union européenne et à titre
provisoire les échanges bilatérales
entre la france et le canada
représentent actuellement 11,2 milliards
d'euros en 2017 et dans les yvelines des
entreprises exportent vers ce pays
l'ambassadrice du canada en france s'est
rendu à rambouillet pour visiter
certaines des sociétés concernées sur
place nicolas landry promouvoir les
échanges commerciaux entre les
entreprises françaises et canadiennes
l'objet de la visite de l'ambassadrice
du canada au smart cité campus de
rambouillet une pépinière composé d'une
vingtaine de sociétés et 500 employés de
l'industrie de pointe aux start up avec
des exportations vers le canada ici nous
avons une société qui s'appelle prod ils
center présentée par alexandre richard
qui qui qui exporte des pièces détachées
du monde de l'agriculture par le web lui
cherche effectivement à exporter au
canada il est en discussion qui est un
grand distributeur canadien pour
distiller ses pièces détachées au canada
suppression des droits de douane mesures
facilitant les investissements dans
chaque pays des dispositions du ceta le
traité de libre échange entre l'union
européenne et le canada
et c'est très important pour nous de
dire que c'est un accord gagnant gagnant
à la fois pour la france et pour lequel
le canada c'est quand même un grand pays
sur la scène mondiale c'est un
partenaire économique important pour la
france on doit renforcer la
complémentarité dans nos secteurs donc
on aime bien
collaborer et vous avez également des
produits uniques et je pense bien sûr
aux produits agroalimentaires mais
également pharmaceutique et aéronautique
autre entreprise yvelinoise paulissen
spécialisée dans la fabrication de gants
à usage médical et vétérinaire elle
expédie entre 300 et 350 mille euros de
produits vers le pays nord américains
on doit faire avec une concurrence
venant d'asie et le fait de ne plus
avoir de taxes nous permet de gagner en
compétitivité et d'être plus compétitif
ça ce marché canadien qui reste un
marché extrêmement important pour nous
c'est à montre aussi la capacité à la
fois de nos entreprises à se moderniser
et à exporter à ce que j'aime c'est 75 %
à l'exportation et notamment vers le
canada les entreprises yvelinoise
exporte près de 85 millions d'euros vers
le canada actuellement 95% du ceta
s'applique provisoirement en attendant
la ratification par le parlement
français prévue à l'automne 2010 9 est
la ville de plaisir s'est mobilisé pour
sa semaine du handicap à cette occasion
hier soir l'association valentin haüy et
le conservatoire de plaisir se sont
associés pour une soirée où les
spectateurs avaient les yeux bandés
sujet de marylène iapichino un dresscode
inhabituelle au théâtre au père manuel
de plaisir chaque participant doit se
munir d'un bandeau pour les yeux chacun
leur tour ils assistent à un spectacle
musical et théâtral les yeux fermés puis
en tant qu accompagner
l'argent une soirée spéciale pour
sensibiliser à la cécité sur scène
nathalie godet joue de la flûte
traversière
elle est entrée au conservatoire de
plaisir il ya 27 ans et apprend tous ces
morceaux par coeur
c'était inespéré pour moi de connaître
quelqu'un qui veuille bien l'enseigné la
flûte traversière
car on voit souvent beaucoup de non
voyants ou piano ou à l'orgue
mais moi je tenais à pratiquer cet
instrument j'en rêvais beaucoup même à
l'âge de 8 ans plus qu'un spectacle les
participants des cours des ateliers pour
mieux appréhender les personnes en
situation de handicap tout simplement
vous prenez ma main et vous poser ma
main sur le dossier de la chaise la can
vous êtes bien on se rend bien compte
que quand on est bien aidé via vie à la
can mais
ça s'est compliqué parcours avec une
canne découverte du braille et ateliers
goût des senteurs tout est mis en place
pour explorer ses autres sens où c'est
pas mal comme expérience parce que
comme on est concentré sur ce qu'on en
g20
on a plus
la sensation du coup il ya quelques
années la semaine du handicap existait
déjà sur la ville de plaisir
nous souhaitions rééditer cette semaine
de sensibilisation sous une autre forme
une forme un petit peu plus ludique et
moderne en rendez vous pour toucher un
public le plus large possible pour une
meilleure sensibilisation avant de
refermer ce journal ces images insolites
des aigles bénie par un prêtre
or son ville organisait sa
traditionnelle chasse allègue le
week-end dernier
la journée a débuté par une messe le
matin pour les aiguiller de rambouillet
le groupe des sonneurs de trompes de
chasse de versailles une chasse animale
contre animal qui se pratique avec
l'aigle royal le rapace le plus puissant
en europe
l'événement a pour but de défendre la
ruralité les chasseurs des propos
recueillis par nicolas landry l'aigle va
être porté par un négligé et en marchant
en ligne très souvent nous allons lever
ainsi gibier qui sera adapté à l'oiseau
qui sera très souvent du lièvre du
chevreuil et parfois ils sont visés les
jeunes sangliers est donc le but est
d'en de d'offrir à l'oiseau les
meilleurs pas la capacité des meilleurs
les meilleures opportunités pour
capturer c'est une chasse particulière
une chasse noble en c'est strahl où
c'est vraiment l'animal contre l'animal
mais faut pas oublier que c'est quand
même l'aiguillé qui a le dernier mot
donc c'est une chasse très majestueuse
très calme c'est vraiment un moment de
recueillement stupide hier avant de vous
laisser n'oubliez pas 4e édition du
festival saint quentin jusqu'à dimanche
sur tv 78 organisé par tv 78 films
documentaires sur le thème de l'espace
sont en compétition
remise des prix lors de la cérémonie de
clôture au ciné cette d'elancourt à
partir de 16h dimanche
et d'ici là de nombreuses animations des
projections de grands classiques du
cinéma sur le thème de l'espace et ce
temps fort une soirée étant x en
présence des frères bogdanoff c'est à
retrouver sur tv 78 aux alentours de 20
heures soirée présentée par le
journaliste jean claude bourret et du
festival saint quentin il en sera aussi
question dans l'émission en 7 8 7 8
loisirs de marylène iapichino dans un
instant elle a sélectionné pour vous
les principales idées de sorties du week
end c'est la fin de ce journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]